hey guys
welcome to DLM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel and I've been a male model for
over 12 years now some of you guys that is starting out modeling asked me hey
Daniel we need some help with the model
portfolio how should it look like
so in this video I'm gonna show you my model
portfolio example and what I want you
guys to look at is the different
expressions with the different clothes that
I have on with the different light that
the photographer's using all of those
things they play together so let's not
waste any more time let's get into the video
all right that's it for the model
portfolio if you have any other
questions about anything else about
modeling check out my modeling ebook in
the video description down below if you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
Cheers